hello and welcome
to the berlin science week event at
carbon free fuel
hydrogen can my name is jennifer decker
and i represent the national research
council of canada in germany
this event will be held in english
however you are welcome to ask your
questions in english
french or german we invite you to use
the q a box for your questions
please note that this event is being
recorded i would like to introduce our
event master of ceremonies
and moderator dr phil deluna dr deluna
is director of the national research
council of canada program
for clean fuels and aims to develop
transformative technologies to help
canada
attain net zero greenhouse gas emissions
by the year 2050 a highly cited academic
researcher with many accolades
including ford forbes top 30 under 30
dr deluna the virtual floor is yours
thank you so much jennifer and thank you
all for attending and joining us today
for this wonderful event on hydrogen
the future of hydrogen and what it means
for
for the world um i'd also like to thank
berlin science week and falling walls
for hosting us on this wonderful event
and i'd like to begin by acknowledging
the land that many of us live on
the land of turtle island also known as
canada has been home to indigenous
peoples and first nations for many
generations
regardless of where you are in the world
right now i'd like you to take a moment
to reflect on the land where you live
its rich history and the peoples that
live there long before you
great so we have a we have a jam-packed
event for you today
all about hydrogen what is it why is it
important
how will it change the world we will
begin with a few opening statements
it's my pleasure to introduce the
honorable stefan dion
ambassador to germany and special envoy
to the european union and
europe for an opening remark
dr rogers scott douglas dear dr mark
costras dear doctor phil de luna
dear drew lyburn dear shanna knights
cher sammy canada dear friends of canada
and dear science enthusiasts i think
everybody is involved in
enthusiasm for science thank you for
joining today's session of the berlin
science week hosted by the embassy of
canada
for humankind avoiding the ravages of
climate change is both an urgent and an
immense task earlier this month
october 7th the european parliament
voted for an increase emission reduction
target
of 60 of greenhouse gas emissions
for 2030 compared to the 1990 level
60 percent and the uh european
commission said 55
it will be a very ambitious and
demanding target to reach
in the speech from the throne september
to 23
the government of canada confirmed its
plan
to increase the 2030 greenhouse gas
reduction for
canada to the target of uh
we'll see but today's 30 but it will be
more than 30 of reduction
and to legislate the net carbon zero
canada
by 2050 and the eu committed the same
zero carbon for 2050.
these are very demanding targets but
needed
so how can we get there certainly not
without
a contribution from hydrogen production
and use of hydrogen will be needed
as a key avenue to contribute to the
decarbonization of our economies
and our societies as a pioneer of
hydrogen technology canada is well aware
of its responsibilities with our new
hydrogen strategy
to be announced later this fall our goal
is to become a top supplier of clean
hydrogen
and hydrogen technology to the
international
markets canada must do that and i am
therefore
proud to address the audience of berlin
science week
and to open this discussion by
highlighting
a flagship initiative and perhaps
a unique effort in the world led by
the canadian government
yes indeed under mission innovation
our partners for today's events natural
resources canada
and the national research council are
coordinating
a major effort called material
acceleration platform material
acceleration platform
what we call map what is map
and how does it relate to androgen well
map aims to fundamentally
change and accelerate the development of
advanced materials
for clean energy generation and usage
by applying state-of-the-art
technologies such as
artificial intelligence data mining
high-performance computing and robotics
and to make what to make the hydrogen
economy a reality
at last new materials will be then
critically needed for that consequently
as an initial challenge canada will
focus
its map efforts on new hydrogen
materials albert canada
can a snitch align chaffin
around this time in 2019
here in the embassy we hosted
a workshop during building science week
to communicate canada's plan to develop
our material acceleration platform or
our map
and since then canada has decided to
enhance
its efforts on irving germany has
presented
his hydrogen strategy in june and the eu
commission followed
in july germany calculated a need of
around
100 terawatt hours for 2030
100 terawatts and the eu aims
to build up 40 gigawatts
in electrolyte lysis for hydrogen
production
canada can help meet and exceed
these goals we will be a great partner
for germany and the eu
recent calls between canadian
environment minister wilkinson
and german environment minister schulz
as well as with european commissioner
for climate actions
timmermans were heavily focused
on their respective hydrogen strategies
and opportunities
for joint action to achieve these
ambitious goals
germany the eu and canada need to join
forces and material acceleration
platform
map is a tool for that consequently
today we are taking another step
forward by organizing this follow-up
workshop
to invite germany and its research
community
to use this innovative flagship
project map and order hydrogen related
research that we are doing together your
workshop today
will help build a roadmap to determine
where to focus our efforts germany and
canada
are on the verge of celebrating the 50th
anniversary of the treaty of for
cooperation
in science and technology between the
two countries
i am confident that with this workshop
that you will
hold today that you will
you will have today and other activities
to take place
next year during the celebrations clean
energy technology topics including our
region will
become more than ever a pillar
of our corporation so to conclude
i would therefore like to sincerely
thank
our partners natural resource canada
the national research council for their
leadership
and for organizing this related
workshop and to you dear participants
following this workshop please do not
hesitate to connect with the innovation
team at the embassy of canada and berlin
consider gislan robicio and trade
commissioner
art houland and with dr jennifer decker
representing the national research
council for our
from our consulate in munich to learn
how
we can cooperate together you with us
us with you thank you for your
participation
and please continue your great work
the world needs it
thank you so much ambassador thank you
for those wonderful opening remarks
next i would like to invite dr roger
scott douglas
president of the national research
council of canada to the stage
dr deluna phil thank you for your very
warm uh
welcome um ambassador diehl thank you
for your very encouraging words
uh to kick off this today's event what
what better way
to fortify a decades-long relationship
between the national research council
and our partners based in germany than
to participate
in berlin science week where we can
engage with and leverage
the international science community for
those of you who might be
new to berlin science week this 10-day
event
gives greater visibility to science to
research
and innovation it's a global platform
for dialogue and collaboration between
science and society
that inspires a deeper understanding of
our world
thanks to the organizers who have shown
great creativity
by pivoting into a hybrid event that has
opened the door
for even more uh diverse uh
global audience on behalf of the
government of canada
and the national research council of
canada i would like to warmly welcome
you
to our session called hydrogen can
which is graciously hosted by by
ambassador dion the embassy of canada
by the national research council in very
close uh
collaboration with our with our
colleagues at
natural resources canada in my role as
the nrc's acting president
i strongly support these international
discussions that can assist us
in our efforts to work towards a better
canada
but importantly a better world through
excellence
in research and innovation and i'm proud
that the national research council along
with
the natural resources canada can help
lead today's discussion and demonstrate
how we are collaborating
with the world's greatest scientific
minds
along with uh phil de luna uh director
of the materials
for clean fuels challenge program at the
natural research council
i would like to strongly acknowledge uh
those of you who've helped organize this
event
including our own dr jennifer decker um
whose uh um council and
nrc's principal advisor based as
ambassador dion mentioned
in munich germany and our canadian
colleagues uh
art ooland and nrc's uh dr mark
caustras a very warm welcome
to the most respected members of our
panel uh drew layburn
uh professor simon teal uh shannon
knights and
and and again my good colleague phil
deluna um
to those of you who are attending
today's session
thank you for joining us in what will be
an engaging discussion
followed by a science slam a
three-minute video competition
judged by our virtual audience your
master of ceremonies and
and panel moderate today is dr phil de
luna who's currently
involved as as ambassador dion mentioned
in the government of canada's
flagship project focused on material
acceleration platform
known also as maps and as part of the
panel
he will share how these self-driving
labs
contribute to discovery of new clean
energy materials phil over to you
great thank you so much roger for the
wonderful introduction
before we begin our panel discussion i'd
like to share with you all a short video
highlighting some of the collaborative
research
being done with the government of canada
national labs at the national research
council
and at natural resources canada um
this short video describes what our
those acceleration platforms on and how
they're being used to accelerate the
discovery of new materials
for hydrogen production could you please
play the video
think of it as a robot assistant who
does the tedious lab work
with a high degree of precision
controlled from a personal computer
i'm gabriel bersan lead engineer
automation and robotics at kanmet
materials
lab with natural resources canada and
i'm leading a group of highly skilled
engineers
and technologists my name is robert
black i am a research officer with the
national research council of canada
my role in this collaboration is mostly
focused on more the science side of
things
i'm an electrochemist by trade gabe
provides a robotics know-how
robert is the applications guy working
together
remotely they're developing robots and
automated chemistry
to fast track hydrogen as an alternative
fuel
the benefits of using hydrogen are the
fact that it's a very green source of
energy
it creates water in the combustion
process furthermore hydrogen
is cheap and abundant typically you can
produce hydrogen from
water second the energy density of
hydrogen is extremely high compared to
say other energy sources
it means that per gram or per mass of
hydrogen
the amount you burn it creates more
energy compared to say
fossil fuels gasoline diesel etc
typically
it can take 10 to 15 years before a
research idea
turns into reality but robotics can
speed things up
utilizing uh maps maps material
accelerated platform we save
money and we save time this is what maps
or materials acceleration platforms
look like think of it as a robot
assistant who does the tedious lab work
with a high degree of precision
controlled from a personal computer
so the maps that we're working on are
focused on the discovery of
new catalyst for the hydrogen reaction
or in particular
the oxygen reaction that is the uh
bottleneck
of efficient hydrogen generation and
this will revolutionize
the way we do research because if we
implement more and more
automation into research we
find ourselves that we can do a lot more
loaded with artificial intelligence
machine learning algorithms
this small desktop robot can even think
for itself
so essentially what it does is it takes
in the data and
as we're talking about self-driving
laboratories it takes in the data and
uses this data to then predict
further experiments to perform in
typically using say statistics or
various other types of machine learning
essentially
to have a better design of experiments
to more efficiently
drive a material discovery process but
getting there
isn't going to be easy we face
challenges every day in
in this field because we're dealing with
state-of-the-art technologies and and
we always have to adapt and make
different
pieces of hardware and equipment that is
not supposed to work with
other pieces of hardware and we automate
it so you just peel off a piece of paper
cut whatever you need peel it off and
glue it and it stays there
working during the kovy 19 pandemic
means
daily video conference calls to stay on
schedule
but the work must continue these days
i'm figuring out how to implement
a new robotic system a new advanced
robotics for this
material accelerated platform this
system could be online and operational
next year
and the end result could be far-reaching
self-driving laboratories what they will
allow is us to accelerate the discovery
of new materials that will
enable hydrogen in some of our everyday
use devices for example electric
vehicles
um and so if we can all afford electric
vehicles faster
and and we're all able to use them
faster we remove our gasoline-based
automobiles from the roads
allowing us to reach our cleaner energy
goals on a much quicker time scale
this project is about making the world a
cleaner
greener place having an energy source
that burns cleanly generates water
will cause the greenhouse gas emissions
to go down leading to a better future
ultimately i want to see the world
continue on and i want
our younger generation to be able to
enjoy it as much as we do
it's important for my family and
especially for the next generation
that to to have a healthy planet and
[Music]
to rest assured that is is in good hands
excellent thank you we will now move to
a panel discussion on hydrogen
technologies
we've assembled a panel of world-leading
experts that represent
academia industry and government they're
here to share their insights on this
exciting field
in a moment i will introduce each
panelist and ask them to give a short
one to two minute description
of who they are and what they do they
will then we will dive right into some
questions
during this discussion i encourage all
of you to ask questions using the q a
feature at the bottom of your screen
we have a team of folks in the
background who will triage these
questions and send them to me and then
i'll ask them on your behalf
so our first panelist is shawna knights
director of technology collaborations at
ballard power systems
welcome shawna
hi thank you phil
thank you okay so uh thank you to the
organizers for inviting me to be here
i'm very happy this is very exciting
event i wish i was in berlin personally
but
it's great to be there virtually so i
work for dollar power systems
which is a leading global provider of
fuel cell products valley designs
manufactures themselves fuel cell
products
they contribute to co2 emission
reductions in various
mobility and stationary applications
bali's products have now powered fuel
cell vehicles in commercial battery
commercial heavy and medium duty motive
applications
for an industry-leading cumulative total
of more than 50 million kilometers on
roads around the globe
so i am a chemical engineer by training
i've been at ballard for 25 years
i'm currently director of technology
collaborations and i'm responsible for
external collaborations with academia
industry
and national labs to leverage leading
expertise and technologies
i think it's very important that as an
industry we work together
and with academia to rapidly further
advance the technology
in order to introduce fuel cells into
the marketplace achieve the resulting
large-scale emissions reductions i'm
also responsible for ballard internal
innovation initiatives to ensure that
our employees have opportunities to
pursue creative solutions and for
evaluation of new technologies
thank you thank you so much
next i'd like to welcome drew layburn
assistant deputy minister for energy
technology at natural resources canada
welcome drew thanks phil
so natural resource canada is canada's
federal department
that works in the forestry mining
geoscience and energy space and i within
that department in
in charge of canada's clean energy
technology
work that's a combination of research
and development
mostly applied r d but also large and
small scale demonstrations
of energy technologies and programs
which
which help companies universities and
other research organizations
do the work we need to do to meet the
decarbonization challenge specifically
we support
hydrogen innovation across the value
chain including the production
from natural gas and biomaterials things
like novel catalysts carbon abatement
safe distribution storage and industrial
end use
great thank you drew finally i'd like to
introduce simon thiele
professor and head of the
electrocatalytic interface engineering
department
at the helmholtz institute erlangenberg
for renewable energy
welcome simon yeah thank you very much
phil and
also thank you very much for inviting me
to this event
like already said by phil i'm a
professor in
electrochemical engineering um
at the university of erlangen here in
bavaria germany
and my main task is to make fuel cells
and electrolyzers more efficient so
hydration technologies
we want to understand how they work how
they age how they degrade on sas and
science
additionally i'm a research department
leader in helmholtz
society it's a part of euleg research
center
it's and we are an external helmholtz
institute in ellen nuremberg
for renewable energy the
academic perspective is to understand
underlying phenomena for functioning of
electrochemical devices and also i see
our task in supporting industry with
knowledge and analysis whenever this is
necessary and also i would like to add
that for this global
task we are having this global
networking is always very important
and i've worked since 10 years with
canadian scientists on hydrogen
technologies
which makes me two times happy to be
here
at this event thank you hello thank you
so much
great so we're just going to dive right
into some questions and and
start the discussion uh let's let's
start with an easy one
hydrogen has been um has a lot of
is experiencing a sort of renaissance
right now everyone is really excited
about it
i'd like to ask and i'll each i'll ask
each of you to respond
why what's different this time what is
it about hydrogen that is so exciting
and what are the most exciting hydrogen
technologies that
you see so we'll start with with shauna
for uh the first comment
i think so sure so what's different now
about hydrogen
is that now the world recognizes the
need
for having a zero carbon future we need
to decarbonize we need to
have solutions to decarbonize our
transportation systems
and our overall energy systems and
when we look at what the solutions are
there are a num
there's going to be a number of
different solutions but for a specific
segment of the
systems the only solution that is
hydrogen
so if we look at the large
transportation systems things like
commercial trucking things like marine
and rail
large buses those won't be served well
by batteries
batteries will be
take away payloads from commercial
trucks they take a long time to
to recharge um they're very heavy
so those solutions for those types of
things hydrogen is
the best solution when combined with
fuel cells
in terms of technology so what we're
seeing is that the growth in commercial
tracking
in marine rail those are very exciting
there's a lot going on in the world and
a lot of different companies are getting
involved a lot of the large
oems are saying well we need solutions
for the future and this is where we're
going
we're also seeing it at the component
level right down to the the components
of the fuel cells a lot of advances
things like reducing the amount of
catalysts with really advanced catalysts
being developed uh working with the the
universities at
new technologies as well
great thank you um drew i'll turn it
over to you now
what makes you excited about hydrogen
maybe in the context of
of what's happening in canada in the
canadian government
well um i mean as ambassador dion
mentioned canada has made
a pretty aggressive commitment like much
of the world is moving towards
in terms of net zero by 2050 and we
realize that as part of that um
net zero challenge there's you know
there's a few pathways we know we have
to follow
you know um i think the the mantra of
decarbonization is that you try and
electrify everything you can
and for those things you can't you more
or less have to find um
either no carbon or net zero carbon
fuels
and so hydrogen fits very well into that
framework and it's the reason why
um we have decided over the last few
years to work with
canadians and engage across the country
to develop a
hydrogen strategy which we'll be putting
out in the next couple
in the next couple weeks and which we
think
actually rises to the challenge that we
know is before us
hydrogen is an essential tool in that
net zero
in that net zero game and canada
thankfully has the pedigree
over the last few decades to be able to
play as a credible leader in that space
that's exciting so everyone you heard it
here first in a couple of weeks canada's
hydrogen strategy
yeah very exciting next i'll i'll move
to simone
um i understand you do work in hydrogen
production and clean hydrogen and a lot
of people are
looking at electrolysis what's different
about hydrogen now
and and what are you specifically
excited about
so i do think that in general
there have been many movements now in on
the political scale
fridays for future for example also i
mean the visibility of climate change
has become
more apparent most people at least see
that there are changes
and also i think that the people in
germany were pretty much stirred
about the movements also in some asian
countries where they are very fast
moving progressively forward and
batteries and fuel cells
and i think there is also the fear
of being lost behind in a way and
for us hydrogen is a very um very
exciting technology
um which which
both in fuel cells and water
electrolysis
i think is our areas that for germany
are going to be very important to
investigate and to be good in the future
great thank you well so we've heard a
little bit on the
on the use side with fuel cells and how
that can help to decarbonize
transportation
we heard about why this is an exciting
opportunity
from the canadian perspective and the
canadian government perspective and
we've also heard
on the german side the the the
opportunity there
my next question is okay we there's this
opportunity
everyone seems excited about it why
isn't hydrogen everywhere today
what still needs to be done for it to be
implemented
can can you speak to the challenges so
again we'll start with shauna
sure phil um so i think you know there
certainly we need to have the the
infrastructure developed but one of the
biggest challenges
has been the cost of hydrogen in
comparison to alternatives
so it's a newer technology as always
that takes a while for the cost to come
down
but a recent report by the hydrogen
council highlights that by scaling up
hydrogen production
distribution equipment and component
manufacturing the cost of hydrogen
solutions is projected to decrease by up
to 50 by 2030.
so once that happens in for a wide
variety of applications
hydrogen will be cost competitive with
either low and zero carbon alternatives
great excellent so production is really
the key here and
the cost there um right getting the
getting the volumes up okay
perfect great bru maybe i'll turn to you
now you've heard from shauna that
infrastructure getting the cost down is
still a challenge
um from your view what are the biggest
challenges you think that
the canadian government should be
looking to address or
um or more specifically in the canadian
context
what are some challenges that we face
yeah i mean i think a lot of the
challenges are relatively common and
ones that we've been struggling with or
or
contending with for for years now um the
first and most important one as shauna
said was
you know we need some of these
technologies to mature and get proven in
bd risks uh much faster than they have
been in the past
um the cost competitiveness question is
a real one
um there is a real um you know even
within canada
you know we've got multiple forms of
hydrogen production currently
um you know we've got the kind of
incumbent um
hydrogen which comes from natural gas
but we're also making great strides in
electrolysis
in other forms of hydrogen generation
but those
those paths will need to converge at
some point um
there's also an area i think specific to
government um and it's a really crucial
one which is
things like codes standards and
regulations these are you know maybe
a bit less exciting than the
technologies themselves but they are an
absolutely crucial part
of the way that technology gets deployed
and rolled out across countries and so
it's an area that we are definitely
focused on and will be part of the
strategy that i mentioned
um we also need to um you know there's a
public relations part of hydrogen as
well
and shannon and and ballard will know
this very well
potential adopters must be aware of the
the
the options that they have when it comes
to hydrogen um
they need to be in a position to invest
you know corporate and public
transportation fleets and industrial
capital
um you know get taken in generational
decisions
so you need to hit those investors at
the right time and make sure that
you know you're not coming to them one
year after they've just purchased a
whole new fleet
so these are all areas where i think
governments the public sector can play
helping to de-risk and encourage
hydrogen
by bringing you know its full tool kit
to bear whether that's rd d
demonstration projects encouraging
deployment
there's tax and fiscal policies as i
mentioned codes and standards
and also ensuring that we have modern
regulations that that are not
um so inflexible that they can't absorb
new technologies in the hydrogen space
excellent thank you so codes regulations
um de-risking uh all of these are are
well they these are big challenges but
i'm sure they're not unique only to
canada
uh simone can you maybe speak to some of
the challenges
uh that you're seeing in hydrogen
becoming a reality or the hydrogen
economy
in germany i know that they're they're
making big investments there so
do you think that we share some of these
same challenges are there some that are
unique to germany
uh and and what are the challenges that
you think should be addressed uh
most yeah thank you so i think
in germany we have this special um
situation that we
were never rich in in
natural resources but we always have to
rely here on the ideas and
the capabilities in engineering we're
having
and for an introduction of hydrogen
technologies
i think it will also be always clear for
us that
we will be a net importer of energy from
outside be it in hydrogen or in oil form
i think the german route or the the way
germans see here is the hope that
we will be able to provide hydrogen
technologies to the outside world in the
in the future
using the engineering faculties that we
have here
and um to to have this as well in the
in the area of water electrolysis as
well as in the storage technology part
which is also a big
challenge and finally also in in the
fuel cell area
and um yeah so the point is here
if we don't have the ideas and if we
don't go on very swiftly
in this novel market so we failed in
batteries i think we have now to take
the chance on
hydrogen if and if we don't do that um
then
uh yeah we will lose in the in the
global competition
thank you great thank you i want to move
now
to explore a little bit more deeply the
relationship between the collaborative
relationship
between canada and germany um i think
it's great that you highlighted earlier
simone um the the number of years
working with canadian scientists which i
think is fantastic
i think maybe first i'll ask this from
the industrial perspective
shauna um what are what are some of the
work that you're doing
maybe on the research and development
side uh with with germany or with german
partners can you speak to the importance
of this kind of collaboration
sure sure so as i mentioned earlier i'm
a very strong
proponent of collaborative activities
and
canada and germany have had a long
history of collaborating on fuel cell
research
as well as on supply chain development
product development and validation
demonstration activities
so and there's you know we have to
continue those collaborations there's a
lot of value there as we learn from each
other and grow
the industry together so some specific
examples
include there's been a collaboration
network between canadian universities
and german universities and labs for
many
years over a decade and
um working on advances in fuel cell
component performance
germany has hosted also hosted many fuel
cell transit bus
demonstrations and we've you know
ballard's been supplying fuel cells for
those
also back more than a decade in some of
the very early
bus fleets and learning how they how the
buses work in
in real transit uh operation
so we've worked very closely with them
and now germany is moving with
commercial deployments they're they're
real leader there and we're also
continuing to work with them
with them there as well
that's great thank you for those
examples um
well i'm going to move now to you on on
hydrogen and uh
on the collaboration with germany and
and could you speak to not only
the collaboration opportunity with
germany but also
the strategic opportunity we just heard
from simon that that they don't have
necessarily a lot of natural resources
um
i i've heard multiple times that
canada could become an exporter of
clean hydrogen um and potentially
germany could be
that that wonderful customer so so maybe
if you could speak to a little bit about
the the collaboration between germany
and canada
and then the opportunity for uh further
not only collaboration but
um uh work together in hydrogen
drew you might be on mute if you are
talking sorry i actually
i think my video conked out there for a
minute could you just repeat that i
actually dropped off for a second
okay sure my question was um
germany and canada the there there's of
course a
lot of history of collaboration between
our countries uh
simone spoke earlier about how germany
doesn't have as much natural resources
uh
and they want to be an exporter of
technology canada has an opportunity we
have a lot of natural resources we could
potentially be
a net exporter of clean hydrogen so i
i'd love
if you could talk uh about the history
or a little bit more about
canada german collaboration and the
potential for the future
sure yeah um you know as as ambassador
dion mentioned at the outset we have a
long history of collaboration on the
science field
with germany in fact my department alone
has 24 research collaborations with
germany
and we're actually looking to formalize
an energy dialogue to strengthen that
bilateral cooperation including when it
comes to hydrogen
and we're also partners together in
mission innovation both on the maps
challenge the
clean energy materials one but also on
what we call innovation challenge eight
which is the renewable and clean
hydrogen
challenge there are a lot of areas of
shared expertise and interest
um as communicated through germany's
hydrogen strategy and i think that
you'll see when
when ours is released whether it's you
know things like safe distribution of
hydrogen through existing pipelines
zero emission hydrogen production and
industrial and transportation and use
but as you said phil there is a
complementarity to our interest
in this i mean canada obviously wants to
be a consumer of hydrogen that's part of
the equation
but we have a unique profile both as a
a country with massive high
hydroelectricity
and renewable electricity potential for
things like exports
of of electricity driven or hydrologist
driven
hydrogen but also given our vast
reserves of natural gas and the
potential to abate that carbon
and make hydrogen from it it puts us on
a unique footing
so while i you know i don't think that
means we're necessarily going to be
selling all of our hydrogen technologies
or
indeed hydrogen to europe or to germany
specifically
i think there's some great opportunities
for for collaboration there but the one
that we're probably most excited about
right now specifically
when it comes to hydrogen is the work
we're doing on maps and the video you
saw at the outset
i think is a great um a great entree to
that
both both our countries have
demonstrated leadership when it comes to
things like ai and material science
and we know um that this is an area
where you'll see a lot more of canadian
germany collaboration
that's great thank you drew i i'm
getting uh
a cool list of questions from the
audience so
rather than go through some of the
pre-recorded uh questions that i had
prepared
i want to start diving into some of the
q a from the audience
so i'm going to ask a question and then
i'll maybe call on someone one of the
panelists
who i think is probably well positioned
to answer it so the first question is
an audience member has heard the term
clean hydrogen
versus not so clean or dirty hydrogen
which is all about how it's produced
um simone can you explain the difference
what is the difference between
sort of hydrogen that has a co2 impact
and hydrogen that's clean so
there at the moment most hydrogen the
world is made from
fossil fuels and certain chemical
reactions in chemical industry
and this hydrogen typically has a co2
footprint which is
can be quite large so this is the kind
of hydrogen of course in the future that
we want to avoid
the big advantage of hydrogen when it's
produced for in
certain processes like water
electrolysis where
hydrogen is produced from water split to
oxygen
and hydrogen the advantage if you power
this for example with renewable energies
like solar or wind
then you produce co2 neutral hydrogen
and when you
re-electrif or electrify this uh
hydrogen then in a fuel cell at a later
point
um this is a completely clean cycle
without co2
and this is the kind of hydrogen we want
to move use in the future there's
this green hydrogen actually there's a
whole scale of colors for hydrogen from
blue violet and so on but i think this
would go too much into the detail
i think it's suffices to say there is
clean and not clean and we want the
clean one
that's great thank you um so this next
question is around
fuel transportation so i'll i'll direct
this to shanna
um how does hydrogen energy efficiency
compare with other liquid fuels for use
in transportation
taking into account production of that
fuel
ah thanks phil um i don't actually have
the numbers on top of my head so
so i won't be able to speak to that but
in general
the electrochemical reactions that and
that's what uh
cells use to produce their energy are
much more efficient
uh typically over 50 percent efficiency
compared to
an internal combustion engine so most
liquid fuels
are power vehicles using internal
combustion
then you have a lower conversion
efficiency
and when we look at the overall
feedstock
going back to what simon was just
talking about it matters
how you produce your your fuels uh in
the future
as we as we see that the use of
renewable energy becomes very low cost
and we're seeing that we're seeing the
drops of
the the cost dropping significantly for
things like
like wind and solar then your hydrogen
produced by electrolysis will become
very cheap
and you're you'll have a lot of it
available so
so generally we see better fuel
efficiency right now for hydrogen
but we also have to look at the how it's
produced and that's going to improve as
we
as we scale up the hydrogen
infrastructure
great thank you so much
it's important to note that we are still
at the beginning stages of these
technologies
and there's a lot of room to improve i
still think um
this next question is around policy and
so i'll i'll throw this one to drew
um one of the audience members asked
is canada looking at mandating a minimum
percent of hydrogen to be blended
into natural gas pipelines similar to
what european countries have already
done
and along that what sort of policy
changes are required
to set up a hydrogen economy
yeah it's a great question i i'm not
going to go into too many details about
what the
strategy will specifically include but i
think it's important to note that there
are a number of
systems already placed in canada that
are are
encouraging for hydrogen production you
know a thing like a
an economy wide and ever increasing
carbon price
is a clear signal for hydrogen producers
about what role they can play in the
future and we all have
also have something in canada called the
canadian or sorry the clean fuel
standard
which um over time is pushing you know
fuels and combustion to cleaner sources
these are the sort of um i would say
baseline foundational policies
that any country needs in order to
really encourage hydrogen production
um but it's it's not the only thing you
know i mentioned uh
earlier that you know you need to think
about the way you know your tax system
treats
various technologies you need to think
about whether targeted
incentives or investments are required
you need an abiding interest
in rd to continually reduce the cost of
various
hydrogen uh production and use um
uh technologies and also you know you
need to have um i think when it comes to
canada an open mind
about what hydrogen means um you know we
do have
a kind of rainbow of hydrogen
opportunities in canada and what matters
most to us
is about you know reducing the carbon
intensity of hydrogen from any pathway
the reality is in canada that well acro
around the world that the energy
infrastructure
we already have in place today across
the globe the iaea mentioned this in the
report last
last month you know puts us on a path to
1.65 degrees even if we don't build
another piece of energy infrastructure
ever again
so we also need to think about you know
the retrofit ability if i can use that
word
of hydrogen technologies to um to
respond to the world we already actually
live in
and so that's why i think things like
blue and green are eventually going to
converge
and we just need to make sure we have
systems in place in canada that can
absorb and accommodate that reality
that's an excellent point drew and i
here within the hydrogen space
a lot of people talk about how hydrogen
is produced
blue green all these different colors
but i think it's important to think
about what the ultimate carbon intensity
of the hydrogen is
you can make hydrogen from electrolysis
or water splitting
but if your electricity grid is dirty
then the hydrogen isn't going to be
clean
and then you can make hydrogen from
fossil fuels and natural gas but if you
couple it with carbon capture
utilization and storage
then the carbon intensity of that
ultimate hydrogen will be
lower so there's a whole um
there's an entire toolkit of
technologies out there each of which at
different technology readiness levels
each of which makes sense in different
locations and at different times
depending on the local jurisdiction the
local resources available
the policies and to your point earlier
drew
also the public perception and
acceptance of some of these technologies
so it's a very um i think what we should
all recognize is that hydrogen is a very
complex
space right now uh and and we should all
uh
this is why it's so important to have a
conversation like this so this next
question is actually to simone
um and the question is to achieve a
competitive
clean hydrogen technology or price
electrolysis or splitting water into
hydrogen and oxygen is key
electrolysis is an old technology it's
been around
for for a very long time i think since
the turn of the last century
what exactly haven't we as researchers
done well in the past that we need to do
now to improve its systems performance
are we limited and how can we break that
limit
yeah so that's a very good question so
very generally
we are having two kinds of signs one is
breakthrough signs where you have the
completely normal concept
which changes the game and then there's
sort of a continuous effort
and in the way of a continuous effort
it's always the same questions we have
to answer we want to go for lower costs
of for for electrolyzer
higher durability and higher conversion
efficiency and this higher conversion
efficiency
as a result also makes the cost
operating costs slower
so in this regard the transition from
the classical
alkaline systems that exist since
decades to now the per motor
electrolysis systems which are
smaller have smaller separation
distances higher
current densities is one of these things
where you go towards
so on the long run towards um more
efficient systems the one more point
about this older technologies
alkaline water electrolysis was that
it's not supposed to
easily follow the the let's say
changing provided electricity of
renewables yeah because renewables are
always supplied
in an intermittent way yeah and for this
particularly the spam the this acidic
water left
for the pen water electrolysis is
supposed to be a very good technology
because
um it can follow these load changes more
easily
so we are still at the point where we
need to make
the hydrogen cheaper and this is by
making the systems we are using for
producing
it much more efficient and cheaper and
there's a lot of potential
um as we are talking about the canadian
german session here i would mention
that we are in a german canadian joint
research
project and there the aim is that um you
want to go to an
alkaline system this is which is as
dynamic
as these normal plant water electrolysis
systems
but at the same time um it's much
less costly and this is a great storage
and i think a good
example on how to work together between
germany and canada here we work together
with nrc
that's great and and thank you also for
mentioning that project the joint
project it's
it's one of my favorites in my program
although i'm not supposed to have
favorites so
forget i said that the this next
question from the audience member
is um i think i'll direct this to shauna
about
uh because in ballard and fuel cells you
talked earlier about infrastructure and
why the need for
infrastructure is so important this
question is
what are some of the challenges and the
storage and transmission
of hydrogen to end users particularly
small end users
though what will it take what does this
infrastructure look like that you speak
of
and you know what well what's the what's
the challenge there
so you know look it'll depend on on the
type of use but if we take the
transportation system
you know right now we i have a fuel cell
car which is very
exciting and we have a network of
hydrogen filling stations in vancouver
which is you know so that's that's the
start so
you know right now we have three i think
there's gonna be six the next few months
so that's that's how it starts you have
to have get those stations there and you
have to have cars
to use them so it's always talked about
to be the chicken and egg
we just have to start doing it so we
have cars driving around now we have we
have the stations
um the other you know
other types of the the earliest adopters
or
we recommend are fleets because then you
can put your
hydrogen in a central depot so that's
why we started with buses many years ago
you have your hydrogen you know at the
at the bus depot
the bus goes out the whole day comes
back refills at night just like it does
for diesel
so it's just getting those those fleets
so bus is a good one commercial trucking
like things like
ports distribution centers
things like large warehouses
where they use they can have the
hydrogen
in a central place and then you don't
have to build up a large infrastructure
you just have to have one tank of
hydrogen or one source of hydrogen
available and you know we do it from
there
eventually we need to have you know
we'll have hydrogen pipelines
we'll start by having a small amount of
hydrogen in our natural gas pipelines
and i think as drew mentioned we have to
make sure our systems our infrastructure
is compatible so as we build
new natural gas pipelines make sure the
materials that are being used will be
compatible with use for hydrogen in the
future as well
so it's having that that vision and
we're looking forward to the hydrogen
strategy coming out and
having the vision to make sure that our
systems any systems we put in place now
will be compatible with hydrogen going
forward
thank you that's great and it's
interesting to talk about um
uh new materials for hydrogen
transportation and pipelines
uh as a teaser in the science slam one
of our science slammers will talk all
about uh
a new way that it can coat materials to
be more resilient to hydrogen and
brittle mint
um in in any case we're nearing the end
of our of our wonderful discussion and i
want to
make the uh to give each of the
panelists space
to maybe speak on something they haven't
uh had the chance to speak on or
or maybe a last word so uh first i just
want to thank you all
for for this wonderful wonderful uh
panel discussion
and then maybe first i'll start with
drew drew
what would you like to leave us with
um i think i'll just maybe reiterate
some of the things i've woven through my
my comments earlier you know hydrogen is
such a broad-based opportunity for
canada
largely because of the diversity of our
energy story in canada
you know we've got one one type of
hydrogen story that might play out in a
province like quebec
which has nearly 100 percent
hydroelectricity
and a lot of expertise in fact soon
possibly one of the world's largest
uh electrolysis driven hydrogen
production facilities
but you're going to have a different
story in places like alberta or
saskatchewan with massive natural gas
infrastructure and i think indeed in
some of the slam
presentations you'll hear about
alternative ways of
extracting hydrogen from those resources
in a way that can be sustainable
so i guess that's what i want people to
to remember when they think about
hydrogen for canada is that it won't be
just one type
of hydrogen story it will be a kind of
mosaic of hydrogen stories that we have
to find a way of weaving together
that reflect the realities of where we
are now with our infrastructure and our
resources
but where we want to be ultimately by a
net zero 2050
that's great that's beautiful i love
that a mosaic of hydrogen stories
that's i love that all right simone what
would you like to leave us with
yeah thank you uh so um i would
really like to stress one more time that
i'm very completely convinced that
hydrogen is a very important part to our
possibly very clean future and when we
see in siberia or in northern canada
where the ice is melting like it never
has before
when we see at things like microplastics
or fine dusts
that you have in china or in or in
south korea i think it is completely
clear
that with the large number of people
which is supposed to be 11 billion at
some point we need
to take so much care to not go over
this rich where we just fall down in in
a certain way
so and hydrogen is both an energy vector
and also a precursor for chemical
industry
yeah so i think it will be a very very
important part and i think we should
do everything we can to push this
technology forward
to to reach these aims that else
might cause us very many problems i
think this is my last words
so to say thank you thank you so much so
it's a call to action
to for everyone out there let's push
hydrogen further
okay great jonah um last word to you
please
sure thanks phil so you know i
completely agree with
what the last two speakers said there's
a lot of different things i'd love to
say but
i want to just focus on the really the
need for
for hydrogen for the medium duty and
heavy-duty vehicles
because there's really a growing
industry consensus that that we need
hydrogen for those
and we have a real challenge to
electrify that factor to electrify a
heavy-duty
motive and and it could use a very large
proportion of our carbon emissions so
how can you offer fleet
operators the benefits of legacy diesel
including heavy payload long range fast
refueling
route flexibility and a similar
operating experience
but also offer the benefits of
electrification so
include zero tailpipe emissions low
noise low vibration
and fast and smooth acceleration well
fuel cell electric vehicles
uniquely provide the answer field
electric vehicles meet all the above
requirements
effectively address the limitations of
standalone battery electric solutions
that are range constraints require long
reach charge times or on recharging
infrastructure
or limited certain routes and compromise
payload but you also have the the zero
emissions
that we need that's great thank you
thank you so i heard a mosaic of
hydrogen stories a call to action
and fuel cell vehicles are the key
that's great thank you so much for our
panelists
uh next now we will move to the science
slam section of this event
um so what is a science slam think of a
science slam as a mini ted talk
each finalist which had we we did a call
to the world and uh these uh five
finalists
answered that call each finalist will be
given three minutes and one slide
to describe their exciting hydrogen
research work
at the end of all the presentations a
voting screen will pop
up in front of you and you will decide
which one was your favorite
so we're gonna hop uh right right into
it hop right into it
um first is uh brock
batachio co-founder at planetary
hydrogen
i'd like to introduce brock and and
brock the floor is yours
awesome can you hear me all right yes we
can awesome thanks phil
firstly i'd like to start off by
thanking you all for giving me this
opportunity to speak to you today and
thank you for those who put this great
event together
my name is brock patakio and i'm one of
the founders of planetary hydrogen
our team set out about a year and a half
ago to build what we refer to as a
climate unicorn
this is a company with billion dollar
potential that can make a significant
impact in the fight against climate
change
but before i tell you about planetary
hydrogen i wanted to take a second to
paint a picture
our world is currently consumed 95 of
our global climate budget for a 2 degree
warming scenario
and nearly every pathway to avoiding
catastrophic climate change
involves the use of negative emission
technologies or technologies which
actively remove carbon dioxide molecules
from the air we breathe humankind will
need to remove
billions of tons of carbon from the air
by the end of the century
but the time is now to both develop and
support negative emission technologies
to ensure we can hand off a better earth
to future generations
and with that being said i would like to
introduce to you planetary hydrogen
by 2035 our solution has the potential
to remove gigatons of carbon dioxide out
of the air
and store it within the world's oceans
at planetary hydrogen we are bringing to
market a process that creates carbon
negative
hydrogen while healing our world's
oceans from climate change
our technology generates hydrogen while
pulling carbon dioxide from the air
and storing it within the natural
chemistry of the ocean
combining hydrogen generation with
carbon removal
is the core innovation which enables us
to leverage the prices on carbon credits
to radically reduce the cost of our
hydrogen production
ultimately enabling us to provide
negative emission hydrogen to the world
at a fraction of the current market
rates so how does it work
the oceans absorb 30 percent of our
yearly co2 emissions and are the largest
carbon reservoir on earth
containing 40 000 gigatons of carbon in
the form of carbonates and bicarbonates
while these serve as fundamental
building blocks to the marine ecosystem
the problem is increased co2
concentrations in the atmosphere
are forcing our oceans to absorb absorb
far more carbon
which is causing an increase in ocean
acidification now what we do
is we use alkalinity to convert
atmospheric carbon dioxide
into bicarbonate which is slightly basic
this approach is known as ocean
alkalinity enhancement
and and can lock carbon dioxide away for
a hundred thousand years
while helping restore ocean chemistry
and therefore healthy marine ecosystems
so our process looks like this we take
industrially proven water electrolysis
and add a mineral salt which means we
co-produce hydrogen and hydroxide while
the hydrogen is stored
the hydroxide which is our carbon
capture chemical
is introduced to the ocean through an
engineered air contactor
or what we call the reactor the reactor
is designed to maximize the contact
hydroxide has with air
reacting with co2 in the air and forming
bicarbonate
another elegant aspect and advantage of
this approach over other engineered
carbon sequestration systems
is the fact that co2 concentrations are
much higher at the surface of the ocean
than in the atmosphere
and we can use the earth's largest air
contactor the ocean
to help us do the work now what's our
impact
imagine a world where every mile you
travel takes carbon dioxide out of the
air
that's the world we envision and are
making into a reality
today half of the world's hydrogen is
used to refine fossil fuels
by replacing the dirty hydrogen used in
refineries with our carbon negative
hydrogen
we can radically reduce the carbon
footprint of regular fossil fuels like
diesel
gasoline or jet fuel or even create
carbon negative fuels from biological
feedstocks
and moving into the future as hydrogen
goes to displace fossil fuels in a
variety of sectors of our economy
our system can provide scalable ultra
clean
low-cost hydrogen production to fuel the
emerging hydrogen economy
and with that being said i would like to
thank you all very much for listening
and i'll pass it back over to you phil
thank you so much brock
thank you next up we have
sami khan sammy is an assistant
professor at simon fraser university
sammy the floor is yours thank you very
much phil
as phil mentioned i am an assistant
professor in sustainable energy
engineering at simon fraser university
and my research group focuses on
development of materials and coatings
to enhance the performance and longevity
of sustainable energy systems
with a particular focus on hydrogen
energy which i will be presenting
next so as we saw from the panelists
here
there is a lot of advancement in the
development of hydrogen energy
and specifically this has led to the
development of hydrogen economy
which is involving uh which as it's
expanding as you can see from my slide
here on the left
would lead to the development of tanks
which would be need to store which would
be needed to store hydrogen
uh pipelines for the transportation and
systems that can deliver and dispense
hydrogen to end users like ourselves
now as a panelist mentioned a lot of
these systems that are used for fossil
fuels
were constructed using steel but steel
has a major complication when it
interacts with hydrogen which you can
see from the middle panel
that when a steel wire which is
typically very easy to bend and flexible
it can catastrophically fracture when it
is exposed to hydrogen for a long amount
of time
so this dangerous effect is called
hydrogen embrittlement
and it can reduce the performance of
some of these steel components
and very fundamentally it occurs when
hydrogen enters into the steel
and causes it to lose strength and
become brittle so in our research
group we are developing these smart
self-healing coatings to
fundamentally stop this hydrogen from
entering and causing embrittlement
now to explain what i mean by these
smart self-healing coatings we can
show their effectiveness on these
polymers that swell
when they are exposed to water so if you
see on the the panel on the right with
experiment one
when this polymer which is uh very small
is uh inserted into water
it can swell up to many times its own
volume within five minutes
but then in the experiment two when this
is coated with teflon
interestingly even teflon is not able to
block the water from entering
and as you may know teflon is a
well-known water repelling material that
is used to
coat cooking pans but if this teflon has
defects and holes then water can find
its way to go in
and then it can cause this polymer to
swell
but when we use these smart self-healing
coatings which experiment three shows
these coatings are able which are
essentially low surface tension fluids
they're able to cover up these holes and
defects and provide protection
so even after five minutes the polymer
doesn't swell and we show that when we
apply this on steel the hydrogen
diffusivity can be
reduced by 100 times and therefore
provide protection to these
steel components so i'd like to conclude
by saying that
hydrogen energy is very promising to all
of us
and we can envision using this as a
clean and sustainable
fuel to drive our cars or heat our homes
but it is very important that this
hydrogen be delivered both safely and
reliably
so it is important to be aware of
hydrogen embrittlement and have
technologies like these self-healing
coatings which can stop it from
occurring
and this can lead to widespread
protection in many hydrogen technologies
and also as the panelists mentioned with
impacting codes and standards and
reducing costs
towards driving this hydrogen economy uh
thank you very much for this opportunity
and thanks for your attention
thank you sami that was wonderful next
up
we have shu liu phd student at cornell
university
shou please go ahead
okay thank you so much phil and
hi everyone it is such an honor to be
here
i'm studio i'm a phd student from
cornell university
my research is about solar water
splitting
so i'd like to take this opportunity to
give you a brief introduction about my
research field
okay now let's get started
everyone said that hydrogen is the next
big thing
as a green energy resource but is
hatching really green
today 95 of hydrogen produced in the
united states
is by a process called natural gas
reforming
it is energy intensive and it makes
carbon dioxide
as a by-product therefore we need to
find
alternative methods to produce hydrogen
in a greener way
studio i'm a phd student in mechanical
and aerospace
engineering at cornell university i have
been conducting research
on efficient hatred production by solar
water splitting which could change how
hydrogen is being produced
think of the process like this you shine
sunlight on the system
to convert water into hydrogen and
oxygen
imagine being able to use sun to get
fuel from water
which is everywhere on the planet this
could potentially revolutionize
hydrogen production and make hydrogen
a fully renewable energy resource now
let's look at the factors affecting the
efficiency of water splitting
from the length of catalyst development
as you can see from the slide a good
catalyst
material should have high activity
stability
and selectivity at the same time
my focus was on how to increase its
activity
and stability by controlling the
semiconducting properties
of these materials from our research
we have found that by surface
modifications
we are able to activate the catalyst
facilitate
charge separations and upgrade the
stability of the material
on the photo excitation in addition
recent advances in a water slating
reaction
on the whisper light provide
opportunities
for utilizing longer wavelength photons
for hatching production this way
there is potential to better utilize
solar energy
to convert water into hatching both at a
higher efficiency
and a greater stability
efficient and economical solar water
splitting
has the potential for producing green
hydrogen
for use in industry household
transportation and production of fuels
and feedstocks by using solar to convert
water into watts we are enabling a
circular
hatching economy thank you so much
thank you so much that was that was
wonderful next up
we have grant strem grant is the
chairman and ceo
of proton technologies grant the floor
is yours
thank you very much phil i'm very happy
to be invited to
speak about proton technologies at
berlin science week
and i've been to berlin a few times i
love it and i hope to get back at some
point
so what is proton technologies we have a
way to make hydrogen at
very very low cost without emissions
it's my personal belief
that the main differentiator between uh
the pace of of acceleration towards
cleaning and decarbonizing our energy
is directly linked to the cost of
hydrogen if you can make hydrogen
less expensive than natural gas for
example uh
competitive it's competitive against
transportation fuels and all these other
things
so that is the key determinant if the
consumers all want to save money
that's the way to accelerate and moving
carbon molecules
carbon atoms around is a very
inefficient
thing to do so with oil products we
we have carbon which adds mass it adds
friction
and of course it adds controversy if you
can leave the carbon behind
within an oil field and only extract the
hydrogen so oil fields are hydrocarbons
and h2o
so it's an energy rich system and the
only thing that is really needed to
release that energy
and pull a lot of hydrogen out is
oxidize the fuel so in traditional steam
methane reforming which is how
95 of the world's hydrogen is made
there's a large surface reaction vessel
and a constant requirement to buy
natural gas
by contrast our process only
takes oxygen from the air and injects it
deep into the oil field
where reactions occur the net result of
which is hydrogen released
and then using a downhole filter the
only thing that can
go into the wellbore and be produced to
the surface
is pure hydrogen so in that way we save
the cost
of compressing carbon dioxide and
putting it in the ground
we save on the cost of the fuel because
there are our the world is full of
half full oil fields and we also save
on the cost of of the transportation of
the carbon molecule
so from a steam methane reforming versus
proton technologies perspective we have
no fuel cost
our operational cost and capital cost
are far far
lower and i think that hydrogen priced
meaningfully below
the price of natural gas is the way to
quickly
get society to adapt people
didn't get off go from whale oil to
kerosene because they loved whales
they did it because it was far far less
expensive and more convenient to use
kerosene instead of whale oil
similarly i believe this transition
comes down to price
if we want to go fast in the absence of
subsidies
we need to very uh find ways like
protons technology
that can price hydrogen below natural
gas
thanks very much
great thank you so much grant finally we
have
abraham gomez fadales abraham is a
research officer
at the national research council of
canada abraham the floor is yours
thanks for the introduction and thanks
all for your attendance
as phil mentioned my name is abraham
gomez vidalias
i'm a research officer at the national
research council of canada
and my current work is related to
hydrogen production development of
biosensor and bioelectrochemical
conversion of carbon dioxide to methane
could you please move to my slide
as we have here in this panel in recent
years hydrogen has been playing a bigger
role on the development
of new energy sources when we look
around
we can see many different approaches for
degeneration distribution
and use of hybrid so why
is hydrogen important well hydrogen has
the highest
specific energy density compared to any
fuel
is abundant as this chemical energy can
be converted into electrical energy
using fuel cells furthermore it can be
produced from renewable sources like
water
in a process known as water electrolysis
in this process
electrical energy is pro
in this process electrical energy needed
can be obtained from other renewable
sources
as wind or solar in addition the
produced hydrogen can be used in
domestic
industrial and transportation sectors as
we can see in this picture
which represent the concept of hydrogen
economy for all this reason
is considered the cleanest fuel however
his main disadvantage is his high
production cost
at the national research council of
canada we are working on a project to
improve
how hydrogen is produced we focus on
hydrogen-produced
production using an anion exchange
membrane electrolyzer
in this graphic we can see the design of
the cell in the electrolyzer
where the ion exchange membrane is
placed between the cathode and the anode
in the anode a slightly alkaline water
solution is applied
and when we apply electricity hydrogen
gas
and hydroxide ions are formed at the cut
then the hydroxide ions are transported
to the anode to form oxygen and water
the main advantage of this type of the
electrolyzer is that it doesn't require
the use of noble metal catalysts
in addition we can use a low alkaline
concentration solution
or potentially poor water fields at the
nrc
together with the partners in germany we
are working to improve the performance
and
stability of this electrolyzer to
summarize this
we believe that anion exchange membrane
electrolyzers
might represent the best option for low
cost and safe electrolysis
however these electrolyzers are early
stage technology
with a relatively low lifetime and
performance
this is what we like to advance in our
project our teams in canada and germany
combine the expertise in
electrochemistry
and materials engineering work on
improving the membrane electrode
assembly
and the catalyst layers i am sure that
this project represents
a valuable contribution that joins to
the current efforts that many
researchers
are making to achieve a sustainable
future
thank you for your attention
thank you so much and and thank you to
all of our wonderful science slam
uh finalists uh your work is inspiring
and i i to to take uh a phrase that is
now my favorite phrase
this has been a wonderful mosaic of
hydrogen stories
now comes my favorite part you will
on your screen have a poll pop up
i encourage you all please to vote for
your favorite presentation today
you will have 20 to 30 seconds to do so
and so i'd ask the webinar master to
please throw the
poll up perfect i see it here and
while while you continue to to think
about which
technology and which uh presentation to
to vote for
i'll take this opportunity to thank you
all again for attending
i'd like to thank the organizers at
berlin science week and falling walls
for the opportunity
i'd also like to thank the team behind
the scenes supporting this event
from i.t to the zoom mastery to emails
and promotion
it's so rewarding to see all of this
come together
all of the panelists today gave amazing
insights into hydrogen and i'm leaving
this feeling
like not only did i learn something
about hydrogen but i'm feeling very
hopeful
for the future of this sector and of
this space
each and every one of our science slam
finalists
gave a wonderful presentation it was
succinct
they were able to pack in a lot in a
small amount of time
and and it was really quite impressive
finally i i would like to again um make
note of these materials acceleration
platforms
that nrc and natural resources canada
are partnering on uh at um
that will be in a new lab in mississauga
uh we are building a new facility there
which will be
um sort of officially announced uh very
shortly the
and the cornerstone of this is is
marrying artificial intelligence
robotics uh high throughput experiments
and machine learning
to help us automate and uh discovery to
it to a new extent
okay so so with that um i think the poll
is closed and we have
a winner um i will ask uh is
roger uh i will ask roger scott douglas
the nrc president
to please announce the winner and
provide some closing remarks
uh roger if you're if you're president
could you please uh the floor is yours
thanks uh thanks so much phil uh my
goodness
uh over the last half hour uh we've had
um uh you know the trade of of this
wonderful
knowledgeable panel of german and
canadian experts
who've spoken to us about the future
that is hydrogen powered
we've all shared not only in the
importance of this element but how
hydrogen-centered technologies
may be the future of clean technology
we've
we've had described this element how
it's produced
transported used and how it could be the
low carbon replacement
for fossil fuels and last but not least
we've heard
uh from a talented very talented pool
of early career researchers and
entrepreneurs as they
showcase their very impressive
technologies
i've just received the audience's
results from our
science slam poll and i'm pleased to
announce that uh
brock has been selected as our winner
congratulations block congratulations to
to all of the fantastic um
uh uh presentations and and and
candidates that presented today
um and uh uh we'll be in touch with you
shortly brock about that uh um
i think that uh you know it's
extraordinary for me uh phil asks for
takeaways
my takeaway is that hydrogen is highly
versatile
versatile it's highly sustainable and
it's enormously promising
uh canada along with partnership with
germany in many ways canada is
is well on its way to develop uh
research and develop new ways
to use hydrogen to advance a low-carbon
future
we firmly believe that in the government
of canada the national research council
uh nr can our colleagues uh that we have
a hydrogen economy
that will help uh improve climate change
mitigation will play an
active part in making the world
sustainable
this topic is particularly timely
as one of nrc's strategic areas of focus
is environmental challenges impacting
our our green planet
including greenhouse gases and climate
change um we we've just announced the
nrc
is going to invest 57 million in
collaborative programming over the next
seven years
for a world-class uh collaborative
research program
uh on canadian uh made clean technology
that that
phil phil will be leading um and
secondly equally important priorities
overcome the environmental challenges
through international collaboration such
as those we've built up with germany
over the last very proudly over the last
five decades
we'll continue to combine international
innovation efforts
with our environmental research
capabilities to ensure a more
sustainable economy for canadians
and the world and we will look to
develop innovations that leverage
hydrogen technologies
and as we do it's only fleeting that we
do not limit our gaze to our own country
but to collaboration
with partners such as you based in
germany we'll continue to transition
towards a low-carbon future hydrogen
offers us a promising solution towards
that vision
everything we've heard today uh with
everything we've heard today can you
imagine a future where alternate few
searches
were derived from hydrogen on behalf of
the canadian embassy
in berlin ambassador dion the national
research council and natural resources
canada
i'd like to thank all of our panelists
uh certainly phil
uh simon uh simon uh shanna
uh drew for their for their invaluable
insights
and to our such impressive science land
participants
uh to our judges thank you for your
participation for your enthusiasm
thanks to all who made this a success at
the discussions today
um look forward to hearing your feedback
on today's session
and and thank you all um
phil back to you thank you so much
at this point i would ask the webmaster
to please put the contact information
slide on the screen
again i want to thank all of you for
joining us today
uh if you'd like to reach out to learn
more about hydrogen or ways to
collaborate
uh with the nrc with natural resources
canada
um with any of us or even any of the
science
finalists if there was a really
interesting technology that
that you want to learn more about please
feel free to reach out to
any one of the people on the screen
right now um
again thank you all dankeshen
keep well and be safe thank you
you